2つのビデオを流して聞いてますってふりをしたらバレちゃって
大問題だ
5倍速ぐらいでこっちをかけて
早く書いていただいて
内容はともかく早く終わらせれば1つを聞いたってことになるから
画面を2つ分割にして5倍速ぐらいで聞きました
2単位取っちゃうみたいな
それはバレちゃうらしくて
呼び出しとかくらってます
コンピューターとか機械のこと学生の方が詳しいから
いろんなことを考えて先生の上を行く
2分割にして5倍速で聞くのも家にいるかどうか分かんないですもんね
まあそうですよね
どっか遊びに行っててね
どこでだってできますよね
ここでずっと回しながら自分は花火でもしてたって言うんだよね
絶対同じ
リギューターちゃんとやってんの
いやーなんかテストがもう60…全部テストなので宿題が多分30から40%ぐらいの成績になって後は全部テスト
前からずっとそうだったからあまりそういう意味では変わってない感じ
テストはライブなんでしょ?
そうそうそう
うん
その場でやるわけですか?
そう
でもそれ終わってるので
それも日本でできる?
いやいやいやそれえっと…
えっと…なんていうかテストの学教室みたいな…
教室行かなきゃいけない?
そう
それまで帰ってないって何もない?
あ、いえっともう終わって…
あの…
最後に3つぐらいの…なんか…論文じゃないけど小さい…
レポート?
レポートみたいなのがあってそれ終わらせなきゃいけない…
うーん…
こがね虫かね
そうそう
こがね虫っぽい
こがね虫?
うん…こがね虫…
あと亀虫が…
あー…カモ虫の子もありますね…
でも私はツヌミ…この匂いがあったってそんなに…
えぇー…
俺も全然言っちゃわない…
そう…
私結局…
えぇー…
カメ虫…
なんでみんなそんなワワ言うんだろうと思う…
えぇー…
ほんと…
私も…
結構…
インパクトが…
全然にわかんない…
全然私も…
えぇー…